OK, we have a voicemail number two one nine two
David P. You can call it any time of day. Here
is a caller who believes I'm a liar. And this is
a double whammy. David's a liar and the show is
playing in the background. This is a classic where
they can't even be bothered to pause the show.
So I hear my own voice in the background
as they leave the voicemail. This is a
a classic as old as time itself. Take a listen.
Oh, my latest
with three women who knew
nothing about the violence in me.
For Gingrich on the right, you're crazy and you're
telling you're lying to your team right now.
Give giving me a little bit of credit. You know,
in the years before, he just cared about how this
came about. Nobody but you
just spent his entire lifetime.
Yeah. So that's pretty interesting. And I have
to tell you, for the Howard Stern fans in the
audience, I know it can't be because sadly,
we we we we lost Eric, the actor years ago,
but that is a dead ringer for for Eric, the
actor, a frequent former frequent regular caller
to the Howard Stern Show. So very interesting
stuff. And again, I don't I've never had gotten
an explanation as to why they can't pause the
show to leave their screeds on my voicemail.
But you can call if you want to send me
a message. Two one nine two. David, pee
real quick. Very exciting. Our good friend Jay
Thomlinson, host of The Best of the Left podcast,
has just published his 15th anniversary episode.
Huge. OK, you go to Best of the Left. Listen,
best of the left dotcom, listen, best
of the left is an actual award winning
podcast. The David Pakman shows an award winning
podcast, but we've only won awards. We give out,
you know, so which makes them less credible.
Jay's best of the left has actually won awards
administered by someone other than himself. And if
you're not familiar with his show, every episode
is a deep dove into a political or cultural topic.
You hear clips from a variety of shows. Then you
also hear Jay's analysis and commentary. So
15 year anniversary for best of the left.
Great friends of The David Pakman Show go
to best of the left dotcom. Listen to check
it out. And the bonus show doesn't. Speaking of a
speaking of award winning from awards we give out,
the bonus show doesn't stop. Rudy Giuliani will
not represent Trump at his impeachment trial. And
I will tell you why. And it's pretty funny. Parler
has partially come back to life with the support
of a Russian technology firm. I know. I know.
And we will talk about a future Trump Presidential
Library and whether Trump would prefer a theme
park rather than a library. All of those stories
and more on today's bonus show get
access instantly by becoming a member
at Join Pakman dotcom coupon code better. Twenty
one saves you massive amounts off of a membership.
And lastly, join us tomorrow for the inauguration,
11:00 a.m. Eastern, 8:00 a.m. Pacific. We will
start with the inauguration of Joe Biden
to the presidency of the United States.
Don't miss it. YouTube, Twitch and
Facebook. I will see everybody that.